avez vous oui ou non évoqué monsieur
benalla avec monsieur le président de la
république
emmanuel macron je n'ai jamais évoqué
donc le problème de monsieur benalla
avant le 18 juillet gérard collomb a
bombardé de questions
plusieurs saillies du député bourguignon
et l'air guillaume larrivé c'est vous
monsieur kraz monsieur le ministre vous
avez vous rencontré quelles sont ses
fonctions encore moins que monsieur
benalla le ministre se défend il n'a
rien à se reprocher pas de dissimulation
pas de manquement de sa part un enfumage
pour la france insoumise moi j'ai trouvé
si vous voulez que c'était deux heures
trente de vide
12h32 rien où on a un ministre qui enfin
vient s'exprimer devant la
représentation nationale pour ne rien
dire pour se défausser pour dire qu'il
ne savait rien ou pour amener la
responsabilité sur l'elysée 2h30
d'intervention qui n'ont pas manqué
d'alimenter les conversations des élus
de la majorité réunis aujourd'hui à la
chambre de commerce de dijon pour une
séance de travail mon sens c'est pas une
affaire d'état cependant sa touche de
près le sommet de l'état et donc il faut
que toute la vérité apparaisse dans la
transparence c'est pour ça que la
commission denquête a été constitué dans
des temps record tout de suite la rd 5
sur 20 dès le mois de mai quand même
andy a pas eu de sanction il y en a
quand même eu peut-être pas assez forte
pour le ski c'est vrai allemand passé
mais il a quand même eu tout de suite
une réaction et puis 20 ans il ya quand
même trois commission denquête qui sont
en place je pense qu'en tout cas on
montre bien qu'il ya personne ne veut
maintenant étouffer la sphère où enfin
que tout ça que tout sorte un fracas qui
devrait retomber très vite selon lui les
affaires politiques bien orchestrée bien
monter parfois même bien manipulé à sont
de nature à créer du désarroi de nature
à créer du buzz par ailleurs mais
sont-elles de nature à changer le cours
des choses je ne le pense pas la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
dispose d'un mois pour tenter
d'éclaircir le rôle ambigu d'alexandre
benalla lors des manifestations du 1er
mai
un quart d'heure et donc le temps que
les gens réalisent